nada me ha proclamado que debido a todo
lo que se ha conseguido en estas
difíciles circunstancias está comenzando
a salir de la huelga de hambre según los
protocolos médicos volver a comer
normalmente puede tomar otros 24 días y
dicen que esta es la parte más difícil
la vall ya ha sido examinado por fin por
médicos independientes que han mostrado
su preocupación por el estado de salud
del opositor aseguran que si seguir
adelante con la huelga de hambre podría
ocurrir que no hubiese nada que hacer
por el pronto hablar resultados de estas
pruebas médicas desde que dejó de comer
naval y el 31 de marzo ha perdido 15
kilos y también ha perdido sensibilidad
en algunas partes de los brazos y de las
piernas las autoridades del centro
penitenciario donde en nava ni está
cumpliendo una sentencia de dos años y
medio de cárcel aseguran que ofrecieron
atención médica en prisión a la preso
pero que la rechazó en todo caso la
salud de nava le ha sido frágil desde el
año pasado cuando sufrió un ataque con
un agente nervioso muy peligroso dicen
que no se ha recuperado totalmente de
aquello